[Music]
hello and welcome to another wolfram
tech talk i'm arben calzici a content
developer and instructor with the
wolfram u team and today i'm talking to
danny lichtblau a senior symbolic
algorithms developer
and he'll be telling us a bit about the
possible emergence of a new covet
variant
thank you thank you arvin
um
so a couple of words i this is joint
work with my colleague john castle who
knows a lot more about biology and
genomics than i do
so people have questions
i don't know what to say send him email
i could try to answer but
uh so
this actually i was asked uh if i could
um
do one of these interviews about some
research project that might be of
interest and this is one that i john and
i had recently written about uh for the
wolfram community forum and if i can get
the mousing gestures correct
this this is what the the beginning of
the wolfram community post looks like
and
in this post i allude to some
incidental slash accidental
things that happened during the course
of of working on this project and i'll
say a little more about that as we go
but the idea was
that i had originally was since
australia is an island country and has
restricted
the
inflow and outflow of people during the
pandemic i thought it might be nice to
get some sense of
how coven might be changing in that
country and this was just at the time
delta was starting to hit there there is
some migration into the country of
course and and that seems to be what
what brought in delta so
what i had is a snapshot that uh of what
took place just before delta
um and and so
i'm going to uh focus on that a bit
uh see if i can get the the mousing okay
and so what i wanted to do was compare
what we see in australia with uh the
main variants of concern
uh so i
i i got all these sequences from i think
it's pronounced just aid might be guess
aid i'm never sure
uh and i took recent sequences uh
from all over the world for the main
variants and uh the the stipulation was
that
i restrict the count to be in the four
to five hundred range i think one was a
bit more
um because a bunch had come in over a
period of one day and i would have had
you to take either three or six hundred
and and so i i did that and um
i load all these sequences and you're
going to see i used alpha beta gamma
delta of the four variants of concern
and also kappa which turns out to play a
key role in this
melodrama
really more of a farce
but i didn't originally do that
originally
i used other variants
some were variants of interest some are
no longer on that list i used what was
called the new york variant
might be iota i i can't remember i used
the two from california
and uh
i think i also used mu
and from what i could tell none of them
were in any way related to
the um
what i saw and i'll explain a little
more of this as we go but what i saw in
australia so i removed those
after doing a lot of this work with john
and getting some really neat results
seemingly
i did some background reading and
learned that the kappa variant
was not the same or even it was close to
but not that close to delta
and that
it had appeared in australia and that's
when i realized
that not using the kappa variant in my
original analysis
meant we were getting results that were
much stronger than they really should be
so that was a bit of a mistake and
after shutting myself into a closet and
sobbing for several minutes i went back
to work uh using the kappa variant and
that's what we're going to see here
so
so i read in the blog post that you're
using and i think that's what we're
seeing here perhaps they're using
alignment-free sequencing so usually you
know to my limited understanding of
somebody with the physics background
when you compare genomes between you
know different bacteria or viruses or
you know whatever organisms you have
your little you know sequences of dna
and then you line them up and you look
for differences so
how does this sequence free alignment
differ from this kind of more
traditional method of alignment well in
alignment-free sequencing in two ways um
the most important i think for our
purposes is that i understand the
alignment free methods whereas sequence
alignment is not a game i know how to
play fortunately john castle does
another difference is that the alignment
free methods tend to be faster
you can throw more data at them you can
get you get cruder results although as
we're going to see they're not that
crude and they give you some ballpark
um ideas of what you're dealing with you
can then
go to alignment-based methods
at a smaller scale
the alignment methods can can be slow
and you you can you know you you can't
just compare thousands upon thousands of
sequences each to every other
but uh but you can compare pairs and you
can compare
many pairs and get some finer sense of
what you're looking at once you narrow
the field down so what i did was the
narrowing okay and i'm going to show
well
we have on the screen one such alignment
free method called
multi-dimensional
scaling
what i do
is take the genome sequences
convert to something called
the frequency chaos game
fcgr
i forgot the r regime
something like that
and
um
and and so this creates a um
a square
image of pixels
that can be seen as a as a signal
and from that we can use image and
signal processing methods to cut back
the dimension
um because this multi-dimensional
scaling mds it's also a dimension
reduction scheme but it it it works well
if the input has dimension in the
say low hundreds if it's in the
thousands you're dealing with hardcore
linear algebra that will bog down
so and and it's based on if you're
familiar with it something called the
singular values decomposition very few
people are familiar with that
it won't be on the quiz
and and so
what we do is project down to three
dimensions doing all this
you know signal processing manipulation
and then we plot the points and what we
can see is that
the pink kappa and the blue delta are
kind of close to one another
i'll never oh i can rotate oh
and the others are pretty well separated
we then um
use a similar
uh set of sim
signal processing tools
to build a phylogenetic tree there are
other ways of building phylogenetic
trees
and and i won't say that this one is the
best possible
but in practice it works well enough and
in particular and this was to my
surprise when i first learned this maybe
a year ago it is good enough as as is
this picture to actually distinguish
variants of covid from one another
reasonably well again there's a fuzzy
boundary between kappa and delta there's
a reason for that they share a number of
mutations
so
let me see if i can yeah so here's the
phylogenetic tree well it's just a tree
that shows
among other things the reds hang out
with the reds and then there's this
big it doesn't look like a big gap but
when you see
that it's a sub tree
that is apart from the red sub tree
where we see the oranges which i think
was
it was either beta or gamma so then we
get to the delta
um
and the
kappa
and i forget why i think this is beta
we're looking at
and you can see that they're really
reasonably well separated sub trees it's
not perfect and in particular it looks
like the last of the um
uh
betas i guess or gammas is hanging next
to the uh
the the first of the other but that
really is startlingly good given that
you described for
for getting these differences listed
that's that's very surprising yeah yeah
i was happy um to learn this there are
perhaps some confounding issues uh
having to do with how the sequencing is
done apparently from what john castle
told me
some labs will lop off a beginning or
ending sequence
and that was something we actually had
to deal with when we did the alignment
based methods to get the aligning to
work is that because like i think i
think in genomes there's usually some
kind of signal that a sequence is
starting and then a signal that it's
ending and are they chopping those off i
have a two-word answer for that
ask john
i will
i think that's i think that's it but i
don't know for sure okay um
john was the expert in all things uh
alignment based yeah but the point is it
might have generated some difference
between the sequences definitely right
yeah okay and it might even be lab
specific as to the protocols that they
use
so
then we throw in the australian
sequences and we do some of these
similar things now for the australian
sequences i had to come up with a
coloring scheme
and i think i had gathered these um
i believe these were all during well
let's see yeah they go from january 1st
into uh
well well into july
and there's about a two week lag i i was
doing this late july but uh
yeah the the the
the time of collection there's always a
lag between collection and the actual
sequencing and then uploading to just
aid
um so we only got into early july so i
tried to color the australian sequences
with shades based on date
and in a way that wouldn't interfere too
much with the five colors already being
used and what i thought i saw
was some
uh
greenery up here from relatively recent
australia
and another set over here
and here is where the alignment free
methods did not do as well as i would
have liked
there might also be some over here
it turns out i thought originally that
these were the sequences that we're
going to
delve into further later and i thought
that they were their own new variant
that was before we had put the kappa
into the mix what i later learned is
that they are pretty close to kappa
they're in here
and uh
they they're pretty close to kappa
because they actually are kappa
but they're not
entirely perfectly kappa
so what we saw in australia seem to
indicate
a um
an evolution of
of a kappa strain possibly into a dead
end because once delta hit it sort of
spread and and probably by now has taken
over yeah it is dominant yes uh but and
kappa uh hit in melbourne
and um
and and they had a bit of a spike but
then uh that i think died off delta came
in mostly through sydney and through the
capital region which i believe is
surrounded by
so sydney's in new south wales the uh
autonomous capital region with canberra
is i believe surrounded by new south
wales
excuse me
and that's where
uh delta first hit but i
i would imagine it spread throughout
just just as it spread elsewhere
so anyway
um
yeah so we can
go up and so so what we're seeing here
in the phylogenetic tree i use coloring
for the dates but i also use the names
short names for these just to get to
know where they're from so vic is
victoria which is the
province with melbourne
and
those are in inside the kappas and uh
now here i um in order to get this to
complete in reasonable time i um
uh called out i i decimated basically i
think i took one out of every four
from each of the groups right so we're
not seeing quite so many sequences as
before
and a lot of these older ones are just
um you know they're mixed in with i
think it's
oh purple whatever i said about it
before i think that's alpha well
there should be a legend at the top so
these are the
these are the data from before then
you've taken about a quarter of the data
from australia and put these in here for
comparison sake so we can see how they
lie actually i think i also took a
quarter of the
others due to skip yes i think i did
that with all of them
so
i've tried it going as much as a half
and then doing the other half and the
results always look about the same so
it's not um it's a representative sample
yeah
and uh all right so we see there's not
much in with the reds and um
there's a whole lot here
with delta
and although these branches look pretty
long
they actually when we do some sequence
alignment
they actually really are delta
they um
this is where the
alignment free method gets a little bit
weak it's and it's probably also where
you need to know
about um
some
the vagaries of pruning the initial and
final parts or or not pruning them
from the sequence because
that that in effect if you if you leave
those in it adds noise
and that can make these appear
artificially further away from right the
the main body of what they are in this
case delta right
so you get these sort of longish looking
tree limbs that makes you think they're
farther away than they really are at
least they're mixed in with delta which
which is as they should be
so going oops going on down
or going back up i should say
we'll see
the um
i believe this is where we're looking at
kappa do i have my colors right i can't
tell if we're looking at gamma or kappa
i believe this is uh kappa and the
victorian sequences all look like
they're really
um
mostly close to a few at the top maybe
not um but it turns out again uh
they're a little bit further
uh than you'd think what we had to use
the sequence based the alignment based
methods to see that right
i sometimes wonder whether i'm getting
colors well enough um i mean my eyes
okay so
now we're on to the part of the talk
where um i channel my inner john castle
uh because this is his expertise and
i'll mention as
an advertisement for the wolfram
function repository where i'm the lead
curator
i don't don't know why that
john contributed many of these
much of the functionality being used
here you can see is resource functions
uh they are in the wolfram function
repository i should say the same about
the functions i used in the alignment
free method the multi-dimensional
scaling the um
the sequence to uh fcgr
the um phylogenetic tree building all of
those are our functions in the wolfram
function repository so those are all in
there and then we also have things as
specific as remove degenerate sequence
differences alignment to position
differences and align nearly identical
sequences so these are all just built
into that yeah john um
john john
built the tools here
specifically so that people could do
this kind of processing and in ways this
notebook
is a um
can serve as as a blueprint for how
others can can do similarly
uh and and it's really neat i was
actually able to use some of his code
uh there was a time when uh he wasn't
available i think he had like a half
week of water wall meetings and i was
able to use some of this code and then
just run run past him the results
okay oh so here we are in the alignment
based code so let's um
scroll downward yeah and it seems like
in the beginning you imported that data
from jisaid and
once you've done that you're just
totally in the notebook doing all of
this right there's no need to leave that
for any purchase okay
and that's thanks in large part to the
uh functions that john contributed to
the resource function yes yeah
the
yes the only reason i would have to
leave was
for coffee break
[Music]
not in notebooks yet unfortunately yeah
not in the notebooks yet
and so
uh what what
his code allows us to do
is
among other things
find
similar sequences
we we compare to the reference sequence
which was the first i believe genome
sequenced out of wuhan
in
i think it was january of 2020
and
the whole world of covet has mutated
away from that since then but by using
that as a baseline we can find
uh the mutations that are common to say
delta or kappa right or any of the
others
now we
we learned from the pictures um
that uh and from some other analysis
that's not shown here that we really
weren't looking at recent sequences in
australia that might be related to alpha
beta or gamma
some of the older ones sure but uh the
recent ones
the relatives were uh
delta and and kappa
and
what we found that that turned out to be
of interest was
not the original
grouping that that looked like an
outlier but this other grouping that was
fairly close to kappa and really part of
kappa
and we were able to
well this is all initialization code in
a sense we use it later
but what we were able to do
is
isolate common mutations
mutations that are common to kappa but
not to that
cluster
and there's very few but there are some
and vice versa mutations in the cluster
not common to kappa and then we're able
to figure out
using the coding sequence regions
and
which is data that john can download and
did
and also using the alignment code i'm
sorry the code that
computes uh amino acids from from
nucleotide triples we're able to figure
out what changes in proteins that get
coded for right and so
that's what all this uh is about and i'm
going to
mostly gloss over it because again it's
more john's area but um we
we we
used this to
get um
some
specific genomes that were
representative of the
victoria cluster
and that's cluster items 1 2 and 3.
we were able to get
specific
items from specific genomes from
delta kappa and alpha
and um we're able to use the differences
and
from these we're able to come up with
a bunch of the um
well we're able to find all the
genomes in the cluster that
seem to have
common differences or have most of the
common differences differences come into
that cluster not found in the other
variants in particular not found in
canada so using this method you've
described uh comparing to that reference
strain you could say if you just looked
at delta versus uh you know alpha beta
gamma you could do something like find
out where the differences in the
sequence are convert those two amino
acids and then say oh okay that's coding
for the spike protein and we see there's
a difference between these three
variants and delta in terms of say the
spike protein yes right so then you can
do that same thing here to see what the
what different proteins are being coded
for for these australian variants yes
okay exactly okay and i mean
i i know
essentially nothing about proteins
uh other than
you're dealing when you're dealing with
say one um
substitution
of an amino acid i guess you can
consider the thing to be you know the
two to be
the same protein essentially but with
minor a minor difference that minor
difference however can have structural
and or functional uh meaning right so
you know it's still the spike protein
but uh you might have different variants
of that that behave in slightly
different ways
so what we've found is that there are
um
in in this victorian cluster there were
uh 11
let me see if i have my numbers right
sorry
there were as many as 11
common mutations
18 genomes had all 11 28 had 10 of the
11. uh five more had had nine and i
think that it's that group so 28 plus 18
plus
51. i think we worked with those 51 we
accepted that that was our cluster
and you know there's a pretty fast drop
off after that after nine first you know
there's
only one none with eight only one with
seven and then it drops off to four you
know so clustered pretty tightly at that
high end of the number of mutations yes
exactly okay
so and and here is a
histogram i guess bins that that show
that
and and so now we figure out which of
these 50 odd uh genomes are uh comprise
our cluster and we can
then um
key in on
on on differences between those and and
the um
representatives from uh the variants and
again we
at this point we only looked at delta
and kappa there they were essentially
these were unrelated to the other
variants
so
the background diffs i think has to do
with um
removing all mutations that are
mutations from the original reference
genome that are basically common to
every every one of these now
and so we remove those from
consideration
and um
so
we see that there are
a bunch of um
protein coding differences between
uh
this
this cluster
and what is nowadays sort of the common
core
um but many of these are um
we will see many of these are shared by
uh kappa
uh in particular i think some are shared
by delta many are shared by kappa
and so
um
so we have to remove those uh you know
it's where what we say here there's a
significant overlap with the kappa
variant but it's not 100 overlap and so
what we do is we show um
what's in the australian
cluster but not kappa and vice versa
what's in kappa but not the um the
cluster and we see that there are indeed
a few uh differences in the uh protein
coding
and so that that's where we ended up
with this i think that is the bitter end
and um
you know in some ways i i view this as
uh snatching
uh victory from defeat because you know
before we thought we had really
uncovered a new variant uh and then we
realized now we have kappa but then we
realize well this isn't actually quite
kappa it's a little bit new
and um what i surmise is that in
isolation
uh variants themselves can and will
mutate a bit
whether these mutations were beneficial
or not i can't say
why some mutations were lost from kappa
uh and gained and and
why some others were gained i can't say
maybe the ones weren't really lost maybe
what came overseas
to australia were uncommon forms of
kappa that already were you know that
were missing a couple of of mutations i
don't know yeah there are a lot of
questions about selection pressure that
one could ask
but i mean at the end of the day or year
as it turns out i think it probably
doesn't matter because delta
has superseded kappa
i tried
in some later work i tried to get more
sequences more recent ones from
australia what i learned is that um
a lot of sequences uh coming out of
australia are not coming out of
australia that is to say they're staying
in australia they have their own data
repository not much is getting uploaded
to just aid
between uh
late july and late august i don't know
if any got uploaded that came from
victoria
so i couldn't really say more
i could have probably tried to get
permission from this consortium in
australia to get at their sequences but
this isn't really part of my day job
and i sort of thought i had other things
i needed to attend to like you know
fixing a few bugs here and there and uh
will from mathematica somewhat important
yeah
yes
so that's where this
landed and uh it was a fun project yeah
i can definitely see what you mean about
this kind of serving as a blueprint for
doing this sort of analysis in the
future it seems like yeah you with just
a few well not a few but uh with just
some sequences being
uploaded and taken into the notebook it
seems like you can do
quite a lot in terms of figuring out
what the real differences are um
again in the in the protein specifically
it's pretty amazing that you can go from
just the sequences to that at the end
you know these are the mutations and the
proteins i was amazed too i mean frankly
uh
i i knew john was good at this but i
when i had the um
the the alignment free stuff up and
running and again when kappa wasn't in
the mix
uh what i had looked like it was pretty
stark differences and and fairly
interesting and
john got excited by that um and then the
uh speed with which he came up with with
this this uh set of tools for doing the
alignment um
and and the quality of results it
absolutely astounded me
um which is good i mean yeah it's a good
astounding yeah exactly those are hard
to come by
agreed yeah
well thanks a lot danny for that very
interesting talk about analyzing a
possible new covet variant and i guess
variant is kind of an arbitrary term
anyway right
yes thank you very much um
uh the last person who tried this fell
asleep so thank you for staying awake
yeah
it was a real struggle
well thanks a lot that was very
interesting and i look forward to seeing
more work on this subject if there's
more work to be done in your opinion if
we get more data out of australia at
least yeah
i i can't predict but um sometimes
something interesting arises and uh yeah
you've got the framework got it and i i
know i know how to get get a hold of
john all right yeah that's a useful
resource to have well thanks again
thank you all right
this has been another wolfram tech talk
from danny who told us about analyzing
different covid variants
and i'd like to note that we have a free
wolf mu course available to you about
doing data analysis and visualization of
covet 19 so that includes kind of the
spread some modeling stuff like that i
think it'd be quite interesting if you
found this talk interesting
stay tuned for future tech talks we have
quite a few more coming up thanks and
have a good day
[Music]